Der Hasenfroh.
Liebe HSV-Fans, ich verspreche zur nächsten Zweitligaligatour werde ich ein anderes Intro gemacht haben. Ich habe es jetzt zeitlich nicht geschafft. Ich hatte das halt noch von der letzten Sendung darliegen. Wenn ihr andere Ideen habt, was man für so eine Zweitligasendung als O-Ton nehmen könnte, dann schickt sie mir bitte. Irgendwas über Willy Landgraf oder ich weiß es ja nicht. Aber deswegen muss ich nochmal –es tut mir leid, dass ich nochmal in diese offene Wunde reinpieksen musste. Es war das letzte Mal schon auf Kante genäht. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen im Rasenfunk. Schön, dass ihr da seid und schön, dass ihr zuhört. Vielleicht sogar, wenn euch dieses Intro ein bisschen wehgetan hat. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetz auf mastodon.social und auf Blue Sky. Und wir wollen jetzt eben sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Und wie immer haben wir da drei Vereine, die wir heute besprechen wollen. Einmal der FC St. Pauli. Das ist ein Teil, den hört ihr am Ende der Sendung. Das habe ich schon aufgezeichnet, mit Tim Eckstein vom Millan-Ton. Und jetzt hier bei mir begrüße ich einmal Anna Niemens von Früff unter anderem. Und ihr kennt sie auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk Royal. Da haben wir den Abstieg verarbeitet. Und wer hätte gedacht, Anna, dass wir so schnell widersprechen müssen? Schön, dass du hier bist. Das ist nie ein gutes Zeichen, ehrlich gesagt, für die Absteiger, wenn die früh wieder drankommen in der Ligatur, dann ist was passiert. Aber es hat Hertha auch schon erwischt, also sei getrost. Eigentlich hätten wir die Runde mit Marc noch mal machen können im Nachhinein, wenn ich das gewusst hätte. Naja, aber schön, dass du wieder da bist. Ja, sehr, sehr gerne. Und dann feiert sein Debüt hier Jörg Ruffert. Er ist FC Magdeburg-Fan. Er hat unter anderem dafür gesorgt, dass ich Magdeburg eine Lesung hatte. Herzlichen Dank dafür. War jetzt aber nicht die Bedingung, hier in die Sendung zu kommen. So läuft es noch nicht. Wobei, wenn ich so drüber nachdenke, könnte ich das eigentlich mal einführen. Also Jörg, schön, dass du hier bist.
Na ja, du hast die Antwort im Grunde schon gegeben. Es ist tatsächlich das Stellungsspiel. St. Pauli schafft es oft gegen Hertha jetzt am Wochenende, letzte Wochenende war das total eklatant, dass St. Pauli gerade in so einer Phase nach Wiederanpfiff bis zum 2-0 haben die wirklich, ich glaube, also ich erinnere mich an keinen Ball, den Hertha ins letzte Drittel bekommen hat. St. Pauli hat die alle abgefangen, die Pässe. Und du sagst, ja klar, mit den Taglings, da machen sie weniger. Das stimmt auch, da sind sie auch gar nicht so gut, ne? Also Quoten haben auch gar nicht so eine gute Quote, was das angeht. Aber haben es dann doch, ja schaffen es dann doch, da gar nicht rein zu müssen. Da sind so Spieler wie Hauke Wahl oder so, der schafft das eher dann über gutes Stellungsspiel, das zu lösen mit ein bisschen weniger Tempo. Dafür aber ja dann doch mit gutem Stellungsspiel. Im zentralen Mittelfeld sind sie gut aufgestellt mit Jackson Irvine, der ja viel auch aus der Luft wischt. Und ich würde dann dagegenhalten, ne? St. Pauli lässt die wenigsten gegnerischen Ballkontakte im eigenen Strafraum zu, hat die Gegner schaffen, am wenigsten bringe am wenigsten Pässe zum Mitspieler im Strafraum des FC St. Pauli. Sie haben den niedrigsten Expected-Goals-Wert zugelassen. Die wenigsten Torschüsse oder nicht ganz die wenigsten Torschüsse haben die wenigsten Gegentore gefangen. Also da ist schon viel dabei, was richtig gut ist. Und ja, klar, die Zweikampfstatistiken, die passen da nicht ganz so rein. Da sind die dann mit nur 55 Prozent Quote nicht ganz so gut dabei. Da gibt es Teams, die wesentlich besser vorangekommen sind, bessere Quoten haben. Aber das ist gar nicht so notwendig, wie der Rest dann so zeigt an den Statistiken.
Sollte es etwas sein, dass die Zweikampfstatistik nicht die wichtigste Statistik und Aushalge, die die Statistik ist. Das kann doch gar nicht sein. Die wird uns doch bei jeder Übertragung angezeigt. 51 Prozent zu 49 Prozent. Na, egal. Okay, aber dann lass doch noch ein bisschen auf die Spieler eingehen, die da in der Verteidigung stehen und auf die Art und Weise, wie sie spielen. Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, sie fangen viele Pässe ab. Wir haben eine Fünferkette bei St. Pauli. Und ich würde mal sagen, gegen Heustan Ki, das war auch ein besonderes Spiel, weil da lief eigentlich alles wunderbar in beide Richtungen des Feldes. Aber was da eben zu sehen war, war für mich als jemand, der noch nicht so viele St. Pauli-Spiele gesehen hat diese Saison, in einem gewissen Bereich durfte Heustan ohne Probleme rein, dribbeln, passen, was auch immer. Aber dann spätestens zehn Meter nach der Mittellinie, würde ich sagen, dann war einfach dicht. Dann war Gegnerkontakt da, dann war es vielbeinig. Also da standen dann eben fünf in der letzten Kette und dann oft genügend davor. Oft dann, ich glaube, 5-3-2 was auf gegen Heustan. Das bin ich mir gerade nicht mehr sicher. Da müsste ich nochmal meine Notizen gucken. Aber wer sind da die entscheidenden Spieler und was passiert denn, wenn ich als Gegner ins eigene Angriffstrittel komme? Was passiert dann mit mir?
Genau, das Problem ist tatsächlich meist sogar, schon überhaupt da rein zu kommen. Ich würde das gerade im zentralen Drittel eher als den Fokus bezeichnen, wo sie versuchen, die Bälle zu gewinnen. Das ist ganz richtig mit der Fünferkette. Davor spielen sie dann 5-2-3 meist. Wobei die beiden Äußeren, das sind die offensiven Außensaat und Dapo Afullayan sind das momentan, die dann doch so eine Art Pressing-Falle aufbauen. Die bieten schon den Pass nach außen auf den Außenverteidiger oder Schienenspieler an. Sie fallen dann relativ schnell auf die Außenbahn. Dann wird sich ein 5-4-1 bildet. Dann schieben sie gerade mit diesem 4-1 enorm rüber auf die Seite. Sie lassen die Ballferne Seite, die wird komplett allein gelassen. Das macht dann der rechte Schienenspieler so ein bisschen im Raum. Und da verknappen die dann die Räume. Das ist wie so eine ganz klassische Pressing-Falle. Was dann meist der Gegner macht, ist, einen Ball zurück zu spielen zum Innenverteidiger. Und dann wird halt hoch angelaufen. Das ist so etwas wie ein klassischer Pressing-Auslöser. Also die haben so einen ganz zentralen Fünfer-Block vorne, hinten eine Kette und vorne so ein Fünfer-Block. Ob der jetzt 2-3 steht oder 3-2, das ist dann so ein bisschen variabel, je nachdem, wie tief oder hoch die offensiven Außen da unterwegs sind. Aber in diesem Block bewegen sie sich im Grunde dann zentral übers Feld. Und wenn es dann tiefer geht, dann bildet sich da mit den offensiven Außen die Fallen dann, dann wird das eine Viererkette. Und dann ziehen die aber auch rüber. Und dann gibt es immer wieder Phasen, und du hast vollkommen recht, es gibt Phasen, da lassen sie den Gegner komplett in Ruhe. Also im Grunde, in der eigenen Hälfte ist es, oder ich sag mal, in deren eigenen Drittel, ist es ganz selten nur so, dass sie offensiv angelaufen werden. Nur eben dann, wenn sie die Pressing-Falle gestellt haben, und wenn dann der Rückpass erfolgt, was ja meist auch eine Rückwärtsbewegung für alle gegnerischen Spieler bedeutet, also nicht sonderlich vorteilhaft für so ein Aufbauspiel, für ein organisiertes, das ist dann der Moment, wo sie dann halt hoch anlaufen. Aber davor, wenn sie dann aufbauen, vorm flachen Abstoß oder so, da lassen sie den eigentlich immer relativ viel Zeit. Und dann kommt es natürlich dazu, dass man irgendwie sagen kann, also alle Spiele, die man gesehen hat von St. Pauli, da ist der FC St. Pauli wahnsinnig dominant, er tritt auch total dominant auf. Du siehst das aber nicht in den Ballbesitzquoten, weil sie eben dem Gegner so viel Zeit lassen, aber die ganze Zeit den Finger am Abzug haben, also sie ganz zeitlich Spielkontrolle halten, obwohl der Gegner da viel den Ball hat. Also das ist tatsächlich relativ wenig aussagekräftig, so eine Ballbesitzstatistik. Aber das ist ein ziemlich klares Verhalten, und da habe ich bisher noch kein Team gesehen, das da eine richtige Lösung für gefunden hat.
Aber wie ist es dann, wenn St. Pauli zurückliegt? Weil da kann es ja dann manchmal auch ein Problem sein. Das sehe ich in der ersten Liga oft bei Teams. Welche, die eben die Kontrolle dem Gegner überlassen und darin sehr gut sind, die haben dann ein Problem ab 0 zu 1, weil sie dann rein theoretisch Druck ausüben müssten, und das können sie aber nicht so wirklich.
Also weiß ich nicht, weil St. Pauli ist diese Saison noch nie in den Rückstand geraten. Und es war letztes Jahr, es ist auch ganz selten, wenn der Fabian Hürzler passiert ist, es gab den Niederlei gegen Braunschweig, Niederlei gegen HSV, da lag man zurück, da ist dann ein komplett wildes, offenes Spiel entstanden bei beiden. Braunschweig war dann, die waren nicht, spielerisch nicht so gut, die hat St. Pauli ganz gut hinten reingedrängt, da fehlte dann vorne aber so ein, ja so ein Turm, sag ich mal, so ein klassischer Stoßstürmer. Oder was heißt Stoßstürmer, ein Bandspieler. Viel oft bei den Spielen, auch die, die lange unentschieden standen, da ist dann eben die Frage, wie man da vor allem eher im eigenen Spielaufbau was machen kann. Ob sie dann schneller den Ball gewinnen, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob sie so viel schneller die Bälle dann gewinnen, versuchen zu gewinnen, höher anlaufen, ich glaube eigentlich eher nicht, aber wie gesagt, ich habe es dieses Jahr noch gar nicht gesehen, weil St. Pauli immer in Führung gegangen ist.
Um die Defensive abzuschließen, welchen Spieler muss man da rausnehmen, dass St. Pauli dann ein Problem hat, seine Stabilität zu halten?
Ich dachte, dass es Jackson Irvine ist, der jetzt auch gefehlt hat, weil er der kopfballstärkste Spieler auf der Position ist und zweikampfstark enorm und dem ganzen Team viel Sicherheit gibt und doch schon so ein Stabilitätselement ist, komisches Wort, aber das nutze ich jetzt mal. Stabilisieren das Element so, das wäre besser gewesen. Aber der war es nicht. Also Conor Metcalf hat da jetzt gespielt, ja auch sehr aggressiv in den Zweikämpfungen. Das hat er auch sehr gut gemacht und ich komme jetzt gerade von einer Pressekonferenz und habe da auch gefragt, wen willst du denn eigentlich einsetzen, Metcalf oder Irvine, weil das ist tatsächlich echt so eine Frage. Und es wird Jackson Irvine am Wochenende wieder auf dem Platz stehen, aber Conor Metcalf ist halt einer der 8er in der Liga dabei. Ich würde sagen, 15 von 18 Zweitligisten steht er immer in der Startelf, so momentan bei St. Pauli nicht. Da habe ich gedacht, das ist der Spieler, der darf auf gar keinen Fall ausfallen. Ist er ausgefallen, hat auch keine Rolle gespielt. Und das ist tatsächlich allgemein eine sehr positive Entwicklung beim FC St. Pauli. Und auch nachhaltige Entwicklung, was mich positiv stimmt, dass diese Tabellenführung nicht nur verdient ist und nicht nur eine Momentaufnahme, sondern dass wir uns da oben dauerhaft festsetzen, dass das ganze spielerunabhängig relativ gut funktioniert. Also, dass das nicht so ist, dass man sagt, wenn wir den Spieler verlieren, dann haben wir aber ein Problem. Sondern es ist tatsächlich so, dass es viele, viele Spieler gibt, die dann neu reingekommen sind, die dann auf einmal gute Leistung gebracht haben. Und die große Aufgabe für Fabian Hürzler ist, das jetzt zu moderieren. Also, wie willst du jemandem wie Conor Metcalf erklären, du pass auf, du hast super gespielt, aber du musst jetzt trotzdem wieder raus, weil ja, warum eigentlich? Weil Jackson Irvine noch besser ist. Ja, klar ist er. Aber trotzdem haben viele Spieler da das Bedürfnis zu spielen. Also da ist jetzt viel Redebedarf im Team. Also es gibt keinen Spieler, auf den man defensiv achten muss. Es gibt keinen Spieler, den man rausnehmen muss. Es ist tatsächlich in dem Fall das System, und dass alle Spieler, egal welcher von den 24 im Kader, die wissen das alle, wie es funktioniert, und die halten sich da dran, und denen gibt das auch Sicherheit, dass sie genau wissen, wie es funktioniert. Und das ist total eine Stärke, dass das spielerunabhängig funktioniert. Offensiv sehe ich das ein bisschen anders, aber defensiv würde ich sagen, das funktioniert alles, egal wen du da hinstellst aus dem Kader.
Sehr gut, dann lass doch auf die Offensive mal blicken. St. Pauli ist die passsicherste Mannschaft der 2. Liga, aktuell 83%, so ungefähr, die Passquote. Man hat relativ viel Ballbesitz in den vorderen beiden Drittel, also vor allem im mittleren Drittel und im vordersten Drittel. Man hat, glaube ich, die drittmeisten Ballkontakte im gegnerischen Strafraum. Und man ist jemand, der aus dem Spiel heraus sehr viele Schüsse herausspielt und dementsprechend auch Tore. Also da gibt es mit dem KSC noch eine Mannschaft, die tatsächlich noch mehr Schüsse bisher aus dem laufenden Spiel herausgespielt hat. Aber dann kommt schon St. Pauli. Und da ist ein deutlicher Unterschied zu sehen. Zum Beispiel zu so Teams wie –ich weiß nicht, ob dir das ein Begriff ist– HSV. Da gibt es noch so ein Team aus Hamburg, die haben zum Beispiel fast 30 Schüsse weniger aus dem Spiel heraus. Also muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, 8. Spieltag und so weiter und so fort. Hängt noch ein bisschen auch von den Gegnern ab. So, aber wie funktioniert die Offensive von St. Pauli? Und warum sind da manche Spieler eher unersetzbar?
Genau. Also ein Wort, was auf jeden Fall fallen muss in diesem Abschnitt zur Offensive, ist Variabilität. Der FC St. Pauli hat auch schon in der Rückrunde letzte Saison und jetzt mal noch viel mehr in der Hinrunde. Sind sie sehr variabel im Spielaufbau? Wie sie initial aufbauen? Wir fangen mal ganz hinten an. Das ist meist so ein 2-3-Aufbau, also zwei Innenverteidiger. Der 6er oder zentrale Innenverteidiger Eric Smit, der schiebt dann nach vorne in den 6er-Raum und flankiert wird er in den defensiven Halbräumen rechts und links von den Schienenspielern. Das bedeutet auch, dass einer der beiden 6er –St. Pauli spielt mit einer Doppel-6, das sind Hartl und Irvine meist –oder sogar beide 6er, da komme ich schon wieder zur Flexibilität, dass die Freiheiten bekommen, nach vorne gehen. Marcel Hartl, der hat deswegen auch so viele Tore erzielt, weil er im Grunde ein freies Radikal ist und sich da frei bewegt. Aber wir bleiben erstmal bei diesem 2-3-Aufbau. Das ist so eine Möglichkeit da aufzubauen. Da versuchen sie dann über den 6er in den Halbraum zu kommen, die dann aufgedreht sind, und dann weiter auf die Außenbahn zu kommen. Idealerweise, wenn der Gegner nicht gut steht, zu Zentrum fokussiert ist, dann spielen sie auch teilweise aus der Innenverteidigung direkt auf die offensiven Außenpositionen und lösen da Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen aus, was auch ein Ziel ist von denen. Und was man auch machen kann mit Elia Saad und Dapo Afolaian da auf den Außenpositionen, die in Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen zu bekommen. Eine weitere Methode, wenn das nicht so richtig funktioniert, wenn der Gegner das zustellt, ist das, was ich als Deserbi-Aufbauschule bezeichnen würde. Das ist so ein 2-4-Aufbau. Da ist nicht ein Sechser dabei, sondern da sind dann zwei Innenverteidiger und ein Zweisechser dabei. Das ist dann meist Jackson Irvine. Und dann eben die beiden Schienenspieler. Die bilden dann sozusagen ein 2-4-4 im Aufbau. Und können dann darüber haben, auf natürlicher Art und Weise, es sei denn, der Gegner committet sich komplett darauf. Man deckt über den ganzen Platz, hast du eine Überzahl-Situation in dem Bereich. Also kannst du im 6er-Raum immer eine Überzahl-Situation und kannst das auch ausspielen. Und da ist die Spielstärke auch vorhanden, um das zu machen. Es haben jetzt viele Teams versucht, sich dann tatsächlich komplett zu committen, komplett in Mann-Deckung zu gehen. Und da hatte St. Pauli in der Rückrunde letztes Jahr so ein paar Probleme mit, weil eben dieses Überspielen, so Schipp-Bälle vor die letzte Kette der Gegner und so, weil sie dafür nicht den Spieler hatten vorne drin. Das haben sie jetzt versucht mit Andreas Albers, der neu im Sturm dazu gekommen ist, so ein bisschen zu holen. Der hat allerdings noch nicht ganz so eingeschlagen, wie man sich das wahrscheinlich erhofft hat. Aber sie haben mit Maurides auch so einen Spieler drin, der das kann, der da vorne rein kann. Die spielen aber beide momentan nicht, weil es anders viel besser funktioniert. Aber das ist so Stichwort Variabilität. Wenn da Gegner kommen, die so mannorientiert sind, wo es Sinn macht, das zu überspielen, dann sind da auch Spieler im Kader, wo man das mal eben schnell umstellen kann. Das würde dann mit einer Einwechslung funktionieren. Beim FC St. Pauli ist es meist so, dass sie zwischen dem 2-3- und 2-4-Aufbau das ausprobieren während des Spiels. Also mal 2-3, mal 2-4. Sie gucken dann, was funktioniert, und dann überlegen sie, das funktioniert Marcel Hartl, der dann vorne ist. Da habe ich schon gesagt, er ist ein freies Radikal. Der bewegt sich auch gerne mal ganz auf die Außenbahn. Mal spielt er als zweiter Stürmer, mal lässt er sich immer wieder von dieser Stürmerposition in Zehnerraum fallen. Mal geht er auch ganz tief und baut auf der Sechs mit auf, um da Überzahl zu generieren. Und das ist total flexibel. Lars Rizka auf der linken Position, der geht auch gerne nach vorne rein, macht diese tiefen Läufe. Elias Saad, der dann auf der offensiven Außenposition ist, der geht gerne ins 1 gegen 1 auf der Außenbahn, macht aber auch gerne tiefen Läufe, geht auch gerne ins Zentrum. Jackson Irvine ist immer der Spieler, bei dem du darauf achten musst, weil das immer dieser klassische nachrückende Achter ist an den zweiten Pfosten bei tiefen Wellen, der sich aber auch gerne mal ganz tief fallen lässt. Also es ist super flexibel, was da gespielt wird. Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Rollen. Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, was der FC St. Pauli geschafft hat. Im Vergleich zur Rückrunde, da war zwar auch schon viel flexibel und viel Rotation, wer aber am meisten rotiert ist, war Lea Pakarada. Und im Grunde haben alle Spieler des FC St. Pauli auf Lea Pakarada reagiert. Wenn der in den Zehnerraum gegangen ist, wenn der in den Sechserraum gegangen ist, dann haben die immer die Löcher zugemacht. Aber das konntest du machen, war alles okay, weil Lea Pakarada einfach so eine hohe Klasse hatte, dass man das machen konnte, ihm diese Freiheit geben konnte. Jetzt wird das auf mehrere Schultern verteilt, diese Freiheiten. Es ist ein bisschen feiner abgestimmt, da sind bessere Laufwege drin, besseres Verständnis für die Rollen, die einzelne Spieler haben. Und es funktioniert eben auch offensiv mit Spielern, die dann auch länger nicht gespielt haben. Also da ist dieses System, das gibt es in Sicherheit. Fabian Hürzler hat gesagt, auf einer Pressekonferenz vor zwei, drei Wochen, habe ich ihn mal drauf angesprochen. Und er meinte, dass man gerade offensiv, arbeitet er eigentlich nur mit Prinzipien, also gar keine festen Laufwege und Abläufe, sondern nur mit Prinzipien. Und da sind eben sehr spielintelligente Spieler auch drin. Jetzt hat sich momentan Johannes Eggestein da vorne reingespielt, bei dem ich eigentlich immer sagte, gerade so das Defensivspiel, das Pressing-Verhalten, das passt eigentlich nicht ganz so gut. Der hat auch körperliche Nachteile, da hat er versucht, einiges aufzuholen, ist aber, wird nie ein Zielspieler sein. Hat jetzt aber gerade was das Mitspielen, das Zusammenspielen mit Marcel Hartl angeht, enorme Schritte nach vorne gemacht und bringt das Spiel auch nach vorne und hat sich da erstmal festgespielt. Man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass der FC St. Pauli noch einen Super-Transfer kurz vor Ende gemacht hat mit Simon Zoller, der hat noch gar nicht gespielt.
Das wollte ich nämlich absprechen. Ich dachte, man darf nicht ohne Mittelstürmer erfolgreich Fußball spielen. Das geht doch eigentlich gar nicht. Wo ist euer Harry Kane?
Ja, genau. Man muss bei Johannes Eggestein schon sagen, dass er unter Fabian Hürzele ganz, ganz wenig gespielt hat. Er hat ein ganz schwieriges halbes Jahr gehabt. Man hat sich oft gefragt, warum ist das eigentlich so? Weil die Zahlen auch von der Hinrunde der letzten Saison, als er eben mehr gespielt hat, nach der Hinrunde waren wir mit fünf Treffern der beste Torschütze. Und deutlich ligaweit der Spieler mit den meisten Ballkontakten im Strafraum. Und auch einer der wenigen Spieler, die einen höheren Expected Goals Wert haben als Tore oder hatten, der es schafft, sowohl im Zusammenspiel mit den Mitspielern da eben ein guter Wandspieler zu sein, auf eine andere Art und Weise, als das eben diese 1,95 Türme sind. Aber er schafft es auch immer wieder in der Box, dann da genau da zu sein, wo eben dieser klassische Mittelstürmer sein muss. Also dieses Raumgefühl hat er auch. Das ist total gut und total wertvoll. Ja, genau, deswegen ist so mit Simon Zoller, hat man gedacht, den braucht man noch. Und jetzt hat man auf einmal währenddessen, während der noch nicht ganz fit war, festgestellt, oh ja, Johannes Eggestein ist ja auch noch da. Und das hat man eben mit ganz vielen anderen Spielern auch festgestellt. Pacarada ist weg, da ist Lars Rizka reingekommen, der zwei Jahre lang hinter Pacarada eigentlich kaum eine Rolle gespielt hat. Und der ist jetzt, also es ist so eine Bank, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Also wie sehr der sich da reingearbeitet hat und auch ja schon im Spielaufbau viel mitmacht und so. Und da können sich viele Spieler werden da tatsächlich an diesem System, an diesem Gerüst, was denen vorgegeben wird, können sich da gut frei drin bewegen und entwickeln sich ganz fantastisch.
Ja, ich meine, das ist schon erstaunlich. Also wenn man sich nur die Zweitligatreffer anguckt, dann gibt es acht Spieler, die schon ein Tor erzielt haben bei St. Pauli, aber nur zwei, die mehr als eins erzielt haben, nämlich Ilea Saad, zwei und Marcel Hartl mit fünf. Also das ist dann, da kommt auch noch so mancher Freistoß mit dazu, wenn ich mich da jetzt nicht gerade komplett falsch erinnere.
Nee, das ist auch, also ich würde auch sagen, also man muss auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt alles Gold ist. Also wenn man davon ausgeht, aber wenn man das als Entwicklungsschritte beattrachtet, dann ist das auch wirklich das letzte Puzzlestück, was ich auch einfügen würde, wenn ich Trainer wäre, wenn du die Mannschaft übernimmst, die sich, die defensiv nicht stabil ist, dann erstmal eine defensive Stabilität reinzubringen. Dann hattest du letzte Saison, hattest du Spieler, die offensiv im Grunde viel alleine gelöst haben. Lukas Daschner, Lea Pakarada, die haben im Offensivspiel, da musste man auch gar nicht so viel mit denen an die Hand geben, damit die da Lösungen finden in der Offensive. Das haben die eigentlich schon von ganz alleine gemacht. Aber dann ist dieses defensive Gerüst, das muss immer wieder stehen. Diese Konterabsicherung, das war ein großes Problem vor Fabian Nutzelaar, die Konterabsicherung. Das hat er jetzt gelöst. Und dann erstmal über die Defensive, über den –und dann ist es im Grunde ja auch ein defensiver Ansatz –sagt er auch super gerne, einer seiner Lieblingssprüche ist immer, wenn wir den Ball haben, kann der Gegner kein Tor schießen. Das ist dann auch so, dann wird so eine Idee bei Ballbesitz entwickelt. Wie können wir den Ball länger halten? Wie kriegen wir, geben wir uns dadurch selber Sicherheit und, und, und. Und dann ist jetzt das letzte Puzzlestück. Du bist dann ein ballbesitzdominantes Team. Du bist defensiv stabil. Und der letzte Schritt ist jetzt das Offensivspiel, was dann sozusagen angegangen wurde, was in der Rückrunde letztes Jahr so ein bisschen von alleine funktionierte. Da musste man dieses Jahr so ein bisschen mehr mit an die Hand geben. Und das ist jetzt so das Spiel im letzten Rittel. Das ist schon gut. Aber es ist noch nicht so, dass ich sage, so damit machen wir alle, also damit wir schießen immer drei Tore. So ungefähr. Also da sind viele so die Entscheidungen, wann St. Pauli Schüsse nimmt. Wir saßen zusammen gegen Kiel im Stadion. Da hat St. Pauli aus vier Fernschusstoren gemacht. Bei dem Freistoß kann man sagen, ja, den kann man schießen. Bei allen anderen würde ich immer sagen, schieß auf keinen Fall, bist du bescheuert. Gerade, wenn die Boxbesetzung irgendwie passt. Da muss man sagen, gerade diese Entscheidungsfindung im letzten Drittel, das Spiel im letzten Drittel, das ist gemessen an dem, was die sonst haben. Die haben die beste Quote, was Pässe ins letzte Drittel angeht. Die schaffen es, total kontrolliert immer ins letzte Drittel reinzukommen. Aber haben dann die Aktionen, die dann ausgelöst werden, dass es dann manchmal nicht ganz so passt, weil die Boxbesetzung nicht passt, weil dann in einigen Momenten die falschen Entscheidungen getroffen werden und und und. Ich rede darüber, während der FC St. Pauli 10 Tore in den letzten drei Spielen gemacht hat. Das muss man dazu auch noch sehen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwas schlecht ist. Aber es ist halt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, das ist das Top-Level der Liga. Aber man sieht diese Entwicklung schon. Da geht es auf jeden Fall hin. Man sieht schon, wenn die das jetzt noch schaffen würden, im letzten Drittel mehr richtige Entscheidungen zu treffen, in richtigen Momenten, gerade auch die Spieler auszunutzen, das Einlaufverhalten von Irvine, das Raumverhalten von Johannes Eggestein, der jetzt gerade erst drei Spiele gespielt hat, das hat gegen Hertha schon besser funktioniert. Wenn man das dann noch richtig einsetzt, dann sind wir…
Auf Jahre hin unschlagbar.
Das wirst du nie rankommen, aber dann Franz Beckenbauer auf Jahre unschlagbar.
Ja, ich meine, das liegt natürlich auch ein bisschen daran, dass in der Offensive immer besondere Dinge passieren müssen, dass du den Gegner aus seiner Ordnung bringst, weil die defensiven Abläufe, die sind viel, viel klarer, weil die orientieren sich am Gegner und die offensiven Abläufe, die orientieren sich an den Fähigkeiten der einzelnen Spieler. Letztlich, jetzt übertrieben gesprochen, ich habe natürlich auch ein Spiel gesehen, in dem sehr, sehr viel für St. Pauli gut funktioniert hat, aber ich habe doch auch mitverfolgt, dass St. Pauli gerade mit dem besten Fußball spielt und sogar, würde ich sagen, deutschlandweit. Also ich gucke ja sehr viel Fußball und es gibt manche Zweitligaspiele, die kann man sich sehr, sehr gut angucken und da gehört St. Pauli auf jeden Fall mit dazu. Aber der letzte Schritt, den ihr vielleicht so machen müsstet, ist so dieser Louis-Fanral-FC Bayern-Schritt. Also du bekommst jetzt schon deine Außenspieler in die 1 gegen 1-Duelle. Das sind Afoulaian und Elias Saad vor allem, der einfach ein krasser Kicker ist. Und was dann passiert, weiß niemand. In zwei von drei Fällen gewinnt sie das Tripling irgendwie. Es kann aber sein, dass er über die Innenseite gegangen ist. Es kann sein, dass er an der Grundlinie steht. Also völlig unterschiedlicher Outcome. Und manchmal verliert er auch den Ball. Und dann müssen auch wirklich alle Bock haben, wieder zurückzuarbeiten, auch wenn es nervt, wenn du quasi mit viel Aufwand dahingekommen bist und er dann doch vielleicht auch mal zu viel ins Tripling gegangen ist. Weil das gehörte zu diesem Spieletypen mit dazu. Und was hat Louis-Fanral als Allererstes den Bayern dann beigebracht? Also wir spielen so Ribery und Robben frei. So, jetzt gewinnen die e-Duell. Und was passiert jetzt? Und dann hat er gesagt, okay, also der erste Pfosten ist immer am 5-Meter-Eck gedeckt. Und der zweite Pfosten ist immer zwischen Torhütter und letztem Innenverteidiger. Und der Ball muss aber auch immer dahin kommen. Und die dritte Option ist hinten am Elfmeterpunkt, im Rückraum. Und als Flankengeber, als Ribery, als Robben hast du jetzt, du hast eine Aufgabe. Entweder du nimmst den Abschluss, wenn du quasi nach innen gezogen bist, alles okay. Oder du spielst den Ball und du hast aber nur diese drei Optionen. Und wenn du eine von diesen drei Optionen, also wenn du dir eine vierte ausdenkst, dann werde ich so richtig sauer und dann wechsle ich dich aus. Und dafür habe ich kein Verständnis. Und wenn nicht alle drei Positionen besetzt sind, dann werde ich auch richtig sauer. Also, war vielleicht auch noch eine andere Zeit, andere Trainer-Generationen und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, das wäre so der nächste Schritt, weil das ist das, was du ja auch schon angedeutet hast. Die Achter rücken schon nach, aber es ist so ein bisschen random, an welcher Stelle sie nachrücken. Der Strafraum ist besetzt, aber manchmal auch so ein bisschen häufchenweise und nicht strukturiert. Und das ist ja eigentlich zu schaffen. Und dann kannst du nämlich vielleicht auch noch Simon Zoller da sehr gut integrieren. Eigentlich gibt es keinen Grund, warum der gerade keine Rolle spielt, außer halt, dass die anderen so stark spielen gerade, also formstark.
Ja, irgendwann ist er auch angeschlagen gekommen. Es war jetzt fünf Wochen lang, hat er nicht richtig trainiert. Jetzt hat er gerade richtig trainiert. Ich glaube, Simon Zoller hätte gespielt schon, wenn das jetzt nicht auf einmal so gut laufen würde. Was heißt auf einmal? Es ist ja nicht schlecht gelaufen. Es gab vier unentschiedene Serie. Er hat St. Pauli nicht das Tor getroffen, sich aber durchaus die Chancen erspielt. Aber gerade so diese Chancen erspielt, wenn man schaut, was der Aufwand ist, den sie betreiben und wie hoch der Outcome ist, dann muss man schon sagen, dass da diese Aufs-Box-Besetzung ist. Ja, doch, Box-Besetzung ist ein Thema tatsächlich. Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Fabian Hützler so detailversessen ist. Die werden schon genau wissen, wo sie wann sein sollen. Ich glaube, er dreht das vielleicht eher um und setzt so ein bisschen mehr auf die Radikalität, dass man sagt, wir wollen hier noch weniger ausrechenbar sein. Das ist, glaube ich, eins. Das hat er mal gesagt, das ist eine seiner Grundideen, dass er das eben möchte, dass man deshalb so viel oder fast ausschließlich auf Prinzipien setzt im Offensivspiel und nicht auf feste Besetzung, dass er eben möchte, dass da viel, dass das noch schwerer ausrechenbar ist. Und dann setzt er eben auf spielstarke Spieler. Marcel Hardl ist, glaube ich, momentan der beste Spieler der zweiten Liga. Da hast du eben, hast du schon gesagt, Elias Hard, wahnsinnig stark im 1 gegen 1. Eine richtige Entdeckung, der auch früher oder später in der Bundesliga spielen wird, glaube ich. Und da hast du jetzt mit Eggestein und auch mit Zoller, mit so einem spielintegenten Spieler wie Zoller, der hat ja damals, muss man ja auch ehrlich sagen, der VfL Bochum ist ja auch dank Zoller oder fast hauptsächlich dank Zoller aufgestiegen. Das war der zentrale Punkt da vorne drin, der eben total intelligent sich da immer bewegt hat, obwohl er körperlich jetzt gar nicht unbedingt die absolute Maschine ist. Das heißt, er wird da schon total gut reinpassen in das Spiel. Ich sehe jetzt momentan nicht, wie man das Johannes Eggestein verklickern soll, nachdem er drei solche Spiele abgeliefert hat. Und dann auf einmal sagt er, ja du, jetzt der Simon, der weiß ich auch nicht, der ist zu uns gewechselt gerade, da muss man den jetzt mal ausprobieren oder so. Das wird eine Schwierigkeit, aber es ist momentan, wahrscheinlich werde ich am Samstag gegen Nürnberg bei dem Spiel komplett an die Wand fahren mit dieser ganzen Euphorie. Das ist für mich auch okay. Ich finde, euphorische Phasen darf man durchaus haben, finde ich, und muss auch so sein, gerade wenn es dann so gut läuft. Und gerade diese spielerische Komponente, die reinkommen. Wir sind jetzt der FC St. Pauli in seinem 13. Zweitliga-Jahr. Ich habe so viel Scheißfußball gesehen, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Ich freue mich einfach darüber, dass der FC St. Pauli jetzt eines der Teams ist. Es gibt mehrere Teams. Nürnberg jetzt am Wochenende, die sind auch so. Die haben auch eine klare Idee im Ballbesitz. Magdeburg ist total toll, das schaue ich wirklich gerne. Und dann gibt es ja noch so etwas wie Walter Ball und so, die auch da viel versuchen. Also in der zweiten Liga passiert schon relativ viel wieder. Also da ist wieder mehr Mut gefragt. Und St. Pauli ist da mit dem Hürzeler Fußball. Das ist schon sehr besonders. Also das ist tatsächlich spielerisch. Haben die da schon echt ein echtes Funt hingelegt, auf das andere Trainer einfach keine Lösung haben? Ich kann mir auch keine vorstellen. Also muss ich auch dazu sagen, ich habe schon mal überlegt. Ich habe Fabian Hürzeler auch schon mal gefragt, wie würdest du eigentlich gegen die spielen? Und er hat gesagt, ja, weiß ich nicht. Wir haben auf alles eine Lösung. Also wenn die Gegner mannorientiert spielen, das war letzte Saison in der Rückrunde, war das immer eine Option, die die gegnerischen Teams gewählt haben. Da hatten sie Probleme, aber das haben sie jetzt gelöst. Also da haben sie Lösungen angeboten gegen Schalke. Da hat er so mannorientiert gespielt, da haben sie das eigentlich ganz gut gelöst. Schalke hat das auch überhaupt nicht gut gemacht, muss man dazu sagen. Aber da hat Marcel Hartel, mit Marcel Hartel haben sie tolle Lösungen gefunden. Und dann mannorientiert heißt halt auch, eins gegen eins auf den Außenbahn gegen Elias Saad und Dapo Afoulaian. Das ist halt auch ein Problem, wenn du die Leute da erst mal hinkriegst in die Position und dann eins gegen eins stehend. Das heißt also, wenn du da komplett mannorientiert gegen St. Pauli spielst, dafür ist St. Pauli zu stark in den direkten Offensiv-Duellen. Nur raumdeckend ist aber auch ein Problem, weil dann gibst du denen eben da den Raum rein und nur aufs Zentrum ist halt auch inzwischen ein Problem. Also St. Pauli hat momentan für alles in der Offensive, für alle gegnerischen Mittel, sie zu stören, haben sie Lösung und bieten sie Lösung an und das schaffen sie auch, auf dem Platz während des Spiels das so umzustellen, also das anzuwenden und das mit einer Sicherheit, die ich beeindruckend finde. Ich bin jetzt seit 36 Jahren alt, verfolge den Fußballer, der St. Pauli sagen wir mal, seit 25 Jahren äußerst intensiv. Da waren schon tolle Teams dabei, aber ob wir spielerisch schon mal so stark waren, das weiß ich nicht.
Jetzt war mal nur noch ein Wort dafür. Hürzeball finde ich irgendwie nicht gut.
Oh ja, bloß nicht. Hürzeler Ball, bloß nicht. Irgendwas wird über kurz oder lang so etwas geben. Ich möchte mal eine These wagen, weil Fabian Hürzel ja auch beim FC Bayern ausgebildet wurde und weil er auch immer sagt, er selbst hat das Bayern-Gen und da ja auch aufgewachsen ist. Du weißt, welche These folgt, aber das bricht sich natürlich alles auf diesen Trainer runter. Und wenn es darum geht, wer ist denn der Star in der Mannschaft oder ist die Mannschaft der Star oder das System der Star, natürlich, Fabian Hürzel, die Quote, die der hat, ist unfassbar und es wäre unfassbar, wenn da nicht sogar Top-Teams auf sowas achten.
Ja, das würde voraussetzen, dass die Bayern 2. Liga gucken und ehrlich gesagt nach allem, was man so über den FC Bayern weiß. Aber das ist was anderes, aber was auf jeden Fall jetzt die Hörerinnen und Hörer verstanden haben, ist, warum diese 90 Minuten gegen Holstein Kiel, auch wenn es 0-0 geworden wäre, sehr interessant gewesen wäre. Denn wir haben auch schon wieder grandios überzogen. Es war ein Überziehen mit Ansage. Tim, ich danke dir ganz, ganz herzlich, dass du uns in aller Kürze, die irgendwie möglich war, erklärt hast, warum es gerade so viel Spaß macht, den FC St. Pauli zu gucken. Und das kann ich wirklich als neutraler Beobachtender bestätigen. Es ist einfach schöner Fußball. Und das gibt es nicht überall im deutschen Fußball. Danke dir, Tim, für deine Zeit. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke natürlich auch an Anna und Jörg, die ihr ja schon vorhin gehört habt. Und das war unsere Ligatur zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wie immer der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. Ihr da draußen, ihr macht all das möglich. Ich habe jetzt für den September 1600 Euro an Honoraren überwiesen. Und die kamen alle komplett von euch. Also vielen Dank dafür, aber keep it coming, bitte. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr wie. Bis bald, macht's gut, bleibt gesund.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funksäule.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.